o lateral diz pessoal daqui quem fala é
o dar que seja muito bem vindo ser mais
um vídeo e os tragos de que faz night 7
fred três tenham calma pessoal este jogo
não é o jogo oficial nem sequer é uma
cópia mas sim um fã de gagá e moça já é
um jogo feito por um fã do fight fredes
é e pelo que eu sei sobre steel pelo
classicismo disseram eu está muito bom
porque mistura o fará e sete vezes 11
finais entregues 2 ou seja nós vamos ter
portas mas também vamos ter mais cara
para não esconder anos é eu acho que
isso vai dar uma coisa brutal pessoal eu
ainda não joguei apenas nos comentários
de vocês recomendar o mesmo muito este
jogo por isso vamos lá então pessoal
ninguém porque o pessoal estamos não faz
night at freddy's um aparentemente
voltar musical porque eu não quero ouvir
porque passaria sem pistas e feijão
pessoal eu tenha mais cara do fábio
neves e fred os dois
o caí aparentemente temos muito mais
salas
o cara está igual a família de fred suns
temos aqui esta sala que não conhece o
que é stefhany nety 32
isto também não vai estar aqui a
história que nós temos fosse light não
temos possibilidade mas temos ali uma
caixa de ser tóxico nem os portos estão
fechados com essa faca que estava teria
meu hábito a porta
ok está muito louco só está muito
confuso stepanek 731 co2 vocês tinham
razão como recomendaram isto não é que
aí eu sei já vai mais gostar né vai nos
estádios a pedra foi a porta foi se
fecha a vida né
será que mills que cinco para ser aqui
quando abria as portas não vai perceber
que enquanto 34% ok já é uma da manhã ou
o tempo está a passar muito rápido
foi aí que o palhaço também está à porta
e não sei por onde ela aparece pela
esquerda ou pela direita mas o andaraí
palhaço deputado pelo pp josé pinto
aqui qualquer coisa meus aqui qualquer
coisa aqui pessoal vejam isso tá tipo em
moto fan caso alguma coisa assim parte
da extinta brutal steel tabutau para
beijar quem finge se foi meu está muito
bom foi o palhaço fecha tudo virar
música do colégio coc steel está mais
difícil pessoal e 73 1 e 2
juntos tipo o dobro de dificuldade e eu
não vou conseguir passar nem primeira
noite eu sei o que o pessoal vai já até
então e agora vou ter mais cuidado com o
zé palácio já se identificar falou de
gelo e vou tentar sempre que eu não saia
do ar é né não você está aqui fora meu
como é que uma equipa dentro
para isso tem que haver uma sala tem a
caixa tem que ter aqui uma sala tenha
caixa meu caixa aqui é o meu pai eu
tenho inteira mas para isso tenho que
ter mais tempo para voltar a jogar bem
vai ser daqui né tá aqui usa palazzo
espera espera e quando eu entrar em
passar o tempo inteiro mas que eu acho
que é isso é tranquilo 85% bateria muito
bom eu tenho que ter cuidado com
espalhasse mel calma tirando haja a
jesus caldas lembra que agora o que eu
tenho que fazer agora tem que fechar as
portas em winter a mágica eu tenho que
chamar os portugueses vão ter mais calma
calma calma foi à porta fechada por 30
mais cara
caí tóxico e não percebi porque é que
aparece o tóxico de ficarem tóxica com
muita máscara
eu vi que alguma coisa está aqui em cima
de máscara por ser uma vez que o filho
da mãe como é que ela parece assim eu
tenho que descobrir como é com medo
dentro da caixa através do meu lado uma
pressa music box é impossível assim
passar junto meu jesus
na outra vez eu tenho que manter este
palhaço para dentro mas como como é que
o metrô palhaço para dentro do meu não
aqui music box quer cá está tudo
tranquilo só para aceitar eu já sei eu
como é que eu já sei o meu ainda ver que
alguma sala tenha music box um deus já
sei um deus a silvia que itaqui o
sequestro calma e os de palhaço também
segundo apronto já está aqui tem que
surfar de palhaço humor sempre por causa
de o meu lá calma vou ter que fechar
tudo agora né
enquanto eu estar aqui vou ter que ter
mais três não sabe só não sei mas o
palhaço volta para a lei
alguém me explica isto o gato longa
fecha a porta a porta máquina lá eu vou
ficar intoxicado com isto será que
ficaram intoxicadas mesmo até o fim o
morro era eu não vou arriscar o palhaço
da onu
agora que eu vou poder talvez na estrada
a porta a porta
ok ok pessoal já saí fugir do palhaço
com denunciar esta sala e os cinco tipos
muito calorosos e ouvir meu não bartimeu
os gastos mal os gastos mal
por que por que zé palhaço porque não
tem jogado para dentro da caixa por ser
eu mesmo não sei mas por se que a caixa
já estava fechada com ele lá dentro
ok vamos ganhar outra vez é sempre pelas
mata meu ok pessoal eu vou fazer o
quinto agora eu vou ficar sempre que
controlar o palhaço para eu não sair
rápido aqui mas também não vai sair
porque ficar sem olhar pra eu eu não sai
é o pior e cujos animatrônicos lá em
cima podem seguir podem marcar mas se eu
ficar aqui
o palácio não vai seguir acho eu né
por isso vamos tentar isso só porque
senão vamos sempre a tocar no rock music
box club voltado à música traz extinta
mesmo muito complicado o caí e não se
esquece das portas abertas lá atrás mas
não vou arriscar em lavre puxar nep chá
é isso
ok vamos chegar aqui e agora tempo por
favor faça o favor da música 89% bateria
pessoal espero que esta técnica do sul
porque senão eu não sei mesmo como é que
passar esta noite está uma da manhã
porque o palhaço sempre me apanha meu os
outros ainda não fizeram nada até agora
e se o palhaço
por isso tem controlado a resultar como
vocês podem ver eu não saí daqui tá
resultar povo não olhe vou pegar só de
população quer é isso não vai mesmo pra
cá não aparece nunca espero que os
outros não e apanhem o sinal vermelho
ainda não apareceu lá em cima observam
sinal é porque eles não serão doados
cima eu michels como se olhar para ele
como é que os encheu seu olhar pra eu
meu jogo está muito bizarro tá muito
foco desafio vamos continuar à espera
pessoal são duas da manhã passou agora é
a hora da resultaram eu demorar a sair
daqui e ficamos a olhar pra eu eu não
sei é se possível voltar atrás com a
câmera os outros vão apanhar mas não
quer saber é sempre o palhaço tem morto
por isso fui controlá lo até o fim
aí foi só o que os postos só rock e
parte em lei básica e 27 poema deus é o
sequela do rock
o zé pinto e só como só querer comer e
os e fred só quer é festa é e josé
raposo que é o meu favorito só quer
enxugar o jato que algo que passe pelo
olhar pros e palhaços e já são três da
manhã entretanto é estar soltará pessoal
se ficar sempre que olhar pra eu eu não
sai não sai o caraças não sei o que o
nosso jovem que está no catar
tavinho eu estava ali estava em calma
calma calma eu vi o homem eu vi a cabeça
dele meu como é que o previsto é que o
ataque agora eu vou ficar eu não vai ser
de que a fox eu tava culpar a pouco eu
consegui avançar até às três da manhã é
sempre olhar o palhaço
agora eu vou ficar aqui em abril não vai
dizer ser depois não são quatro da mãe é
isto tá resultar eu nunca passei até às
quatro da manhã e nesta noite ficar a
olhar para eu dar resultado e não sei se
está em um bom ritmo algo sim por si mas
a meu ver é a única forma de evitar o
palhaço e se ficar a olhar sempre para
eu eu não salto em cima e tentar juntar
são quatro da manhã
ainda lá por favor se chega aqui é
porque vai atacar a 4
por favor não vá lá eu já fiquei muito
preocupada com a portaria são são não
tem 66% bateria resultado foi também
destruído resulta muito bem e agora é só
esperar né
os outros nem se mexem com o cinemata
com isso os palhaços esta noite temos só
de palavras por isso deve ser mesmo essa
forma de passar esta noite às cinco da
manhã o pessoal eu sou mais um pouco
porque um pedaço só mais um pouquinho
também tu com 60% bateria o que é o são
para sempre da manhã é porque eu nem me
tirem portas nem câmeras nem mais nem
nawa software emprego lá lá consegui
caraças conseguiu cair este é outro
ficaram da população
chupa filho da mãe o cair
se não conseguir o que será que eu era
garoto dentro da máscara assistente
porque o zé carlos e entrou hoje entro
em três noites né
este tipo fábio neves e fred 2 está
acontecendo faz média de 42 para parecer
que bicho mesmo daqui só conseguiram
fred repente eu sair com ela e também à
frente à u
respirar é assim tanto calma não fizesse
nada porém que o gestor ficar só após
aplauso de 5 que é pra dar saída então é
só ao justificar porque com isso five
nights é fredes 3 é eu vou deixar um
link de inscrição para você experimentar
em um jogo e verem se gostam imazita
brutal que só eu tô adorar querem ver
mais disso julgo mais episódio não sair
até deixem ver o que isto tem noite dois
exatamente eu não sei até que noite é
que este jogo tem mas querem ver mais
comenta embaixo pessoal e se o vídeo
hoje tiveram um bom feedback é eu ainda
me estou a segunda noite ainda uso
pessoal por isso a poeira mesmo este
vídeo então é isso pessoal fique bem e
até a próxima
[Música]
to